so the first day in mariopol in the
hospital when I switched on the body cam
I didn't think it was something special
but after some time I realized the value
of those recordings realized how
important they were for history and
Humanity
because I understood that there was a
danger of death and I thought there was
a possibility I wouldn't survive and you
protected plenty of Ukrainian soldiers
and people who've been injured in the in
the invasion we've also
had to look after some Russian soldiers
who were injured as well
of course I see every individual as a
human there is no difference for me they
are all patients they all need treatment
and of course we're extremely angry that
they're killing so many ukrainians we
wouldn't call them brothers but they are
humans to us
they're just very unfortunate to be born
in such a country and then you were
taken suddenly
what happened at that moment talk to us
about the moment that they did come and
get you
um
well they stopped the bus I was taking
the children and women out of mariopol
and they said they didn't even ask just
show us your documents
they looked at my passport they looked
at my last name thought about it and
went into the building to the checkpoint
they were absent for several minutes
they came out and the conversation
turned and became hostile
I never know how true this is I've never
been in captivity but I've I've heard it
said yeah let me I've heard it said that
um when you go into a prison you do two
days the one the day you go in and the
day you come out but you were there for
for three months can you can you talk to
us what that was like day to day when
you knew that you were being held by
these people who didn't want
the Ukraine you need to exist anymore
at first the days were very different no
day was like the next
but then with time they became more
alike they merged together though things
were slightly different
the hell I went through
Ordinary People would be Keen to forget
while being tortured they were trying to
force me to stay on camera I was selling
body organs if I was killing somebody
they tried to get proof for themselves
of something but of course not a single
country would accept those as evidence
taught us about the day that you were
you were released
there's like a slit in the door which
opens like a narrow little window that
opened and they shouted through this
narrow seat payevska collect your things
and out and basically they took me out I
had no idea they didn't tell me where or
how or what they were going to do with
me they told me to wait in a particular
room and took me into a car and took me
out somewhere on the outskirts after
some time they exchanged me
before I made the decision that no one
would ever touch my body again but when
I saw the soldiers our Ukrainian
soldiers
are Ukrainian soldiers
I ran to them and hugged them summer I
did
not
saying
and my friends as well
is there more you'd like to see
Britain and the West America doing to
help Ukraine
we need more weapons because Russia only
understands the language of weapons so
it follows then that while that regime
of Vladimir Putin is in the Kremlin you
can't see there being an end to this
fighting
we can see what they are now asking for
talks it means they understood the stage
of the war they could not fight us or
make us surrender through weapons but
what they really want is to have a
breather so they can bring in more
reinforcements and try again
you know nobody believed that Ukrainian
would last more than three days
I can see Ukraine not just be building
the country but building a new country